date you first and then we're going to
El Paso and we'll be meeting with first
responders law enforcement some of the
victims and paying my respects in
regards I'll be going with the first
lady and terrific opportunity really to
congratulate some of the the police in
law enforcement the job they've done was
incredible really interesting
so my critics are political people
they're trying to make point in many
cases they're running for president and
they're very low in the polls a couple
of them in particular very low in the
poll if you look at dating that was a
person that supported I guess you would
say Bernie Sanders I understood Antipa I
understood Elizabeth Warren I understood
had nothing to do with President Trump
so these are people that are looking for
political gain I don't think they're
getting it and as much as possible I've
tried to stay out of that
[Music]
well I do agree but I think we have
toned it down we've been hitting we've
been getting hit left and right from
everybody many of the people I don't
know a couple of people from Texas
political people from Texas that aren't
doing very well I guess somebody said
the mayor I had one very nice
conversation with the mayor of Dayton
could not have been nicer and then she
goes and says I tried to call him while
I spoke to her and I didn't receive any
coal so they're trying to make political
points I don't think it works because
you know I would like to stay out of the
political fray as I was saying and just
came out the Dayton situation he was a
fan of Antipa he was a fan of Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren nothing to
do with Trump but nobody ever mentioned
said say it
no I don't blame the Lizabeth Warren and
I don't blame any Sanders in the case of
Ohio and I don't blame anybody I blame
these are sick people these are people
that are really mentally ill mentally
disturbed it's a mental problem and
we're going to be meeting we're going to
be meeting with members of Congress I've
already got meeting scheduled and I have
had plenty of talks over the last two
days and I think something's going to be
come up with we're going to come up with
something that's going to be really very
good beyond anything that's been done so
far
well we're gonna see where we are we're
dealing with leadership right now and
you know you have two sides that are
very different than this issue and let's
say all good people but two sides that
are very different if we get close I
will bring them back but it has to be
you know we have to see where we are
with leadership normally this has been
really a decision Congress gets together
and they try and do something but if you
look over the last 30 years not a lot
has been done
[Music]
well I'm looking to do background checks
I think background checks are important
I don't want to put guns into the hands
of mentally unstable people or people
with rage you're eight six people I
don't wanna I'm well I'm all in favor of
well I can tell you that there is no
political appetite for that at this
moment if you look at said you can speak
you can do your own calling and there's
no political appetite problem from the
standpoint of legislature but I will
certainly bring that up I'll bring that
up with one of the boys there's a great
appetite and I mean a very strong
appetite for background checks and I
think we can bring up background checks
like we've never had before I think both
Republican and Democrat are getting
close to a bill on doing something on
background
[Music]
South Korea and I have made a deal
they've agreed to pay a lot more money
toward the United States as you know
we've got thirty two thousand soldiers
on South Korean soil and we've been
helping them for about eighty two years
and we get nothing we get virtually
nothing and South Korea and I have made
a deal where they're paying a lot more
money and they're going to pay a lot
more money and the relationship is a
very good one
but I felt all along I felt for years it
was a very unfair one so they've agreed
to pay a lot more and they will agree to
pay a lot more than that and we're with
them we're with them
so you have to have a political appetite
within Congress and so far I haven't not
seen that I mean I can only do what I
can do I think there's a great appetite
to do something with regard to making
sure that mentally unstable seriously
ill people aren't carrying guns I've
never seen the appetite as strong as it
is now I have not seen it with regard to
certain types of weapon
I am concerned about the rise of any
group of hate I don't like it any group
of hate I am whether it's white
supremacy whether it's any other kind of
supremacy whether it's Antipa whether
it's any group of hate I am very
concerned about it and I'll do something
about
no I don't think my rhetoric tense at
all I think my rhetoric is a very it
brings people together our country is
doing incredibly well China is not doing
well if you look at the great situation
China just admitted yesterday that
they've been a currency manipulator
first time they've ever been walled out
companies are moving out of China by the
thousands and our country is doing very
well we're going to see how it all works
out somebody had to do this with China
because they were taken hundreds of
billions of dollars a year out of the
United States and somebody had to make
it stand now I think our country is
doing really well
and what I think the market I think the
market reaction is anticipated I would
have been dissipated I would have maybe
anticipated even more but ultimately
it's going to go much higher than it
ever would have done because China was
like an anchor on us China was killing
us with unfair trade deals the people
that allowed that to happen or at this
great China what they were doing to us
the years and years making hundreds of
billions of dollars out stealing
intellectual property targeting our
farmers all of that ending and they
understand
that's right I'll be I'll be convincing
some people to do things that they don't
want to do and that means people in
jobless but you get a lot of people on
one side and you have a lot of people in
the other but I can I have a lot of
influence with a lot of people and I
want to convince them to do the right
thing and I will tell you we've made a
lot of headway in the last three days
I think that illegal
emigrate you don't get about illegal
immigration yes I think illegal
immigration is a terrible thing for this
country I think you have to come in
Legally ideally you have to come in with
merit we need people coming in because
we have many companies coming into our
country they're pouring in and I think
the illegal immigration is a very bad
thing for our country I think open
borders are